[Music]
nemzer with sicilian that is e4 c5
knight to f3
and now
knight to f6
is a surprising guest at the chessboard
and that's why no wonder many modern
masters has included this line in the
rapprota
however whenever you meet this line
in your life
you will be thankful to me
if you watch this video until the end
because
not only you are going to learn a mini
rafruta against it
but
i am also going to show you
some cool tricks and traps exist
in this line from the white perspective
okay here my proposal is
you continue with knight to c3
and black has choice
if we continue with moves such as
knight to c6 or d6
then we are back into the open sicilian
with d4
and after c captures d4 and knight
captures d4
depending on the black response
you can go ahead with your white open
raputa
so that's the easiest part
but the proper nimso with sicilian start
with
d5
taking the center
so white response is forced he has to
eliminate the d-pawn
and after knight takes
i propose this very important check
which sets up the platform
for our upcoming tricks
well black has two choices and amongst
them bishop to d7 is the main line
however let's start with knight to c6
which is the second most popular choice
where i am going to demonstrate our
first trick starting with
castle on the king side
so if allowed white will definitely chop
on c6
and destroy black pawn structure
and
pay attention guys as black cannot
prevent this by playing bishop to d7 or
moving the queen as is knight on d5
hanging
so what happens in the most of the game
is
black goes for this line
knight capture c3
pawn capture c3
now the black queen is hanging with jack
so black exchange the queen
and finally
defend his knight with bishop to d7
so at first sight this position looks
very innocent
but just see
how amazing trick exists
even in this innocent position
white plays bishop to e3 attacking the
pawn
so the nature response is e6
defending
and after this
the deadly reply
knight to g5
and believe me
lot of people has fallen into this
they have either considered the move
bishop to e7 f6 or e6
which all leads to disaster
why
what happened
so let's say the most frequent choices
bishop to e7
after that
yup you indeed see this deciding move
bam
so suddenly white is a clear pawn up
and the black king cannot take it as the
bishop on d7 hangs
and top up everything the most funny
part is if black continue with rook to
f8
then after knight to d6 jack bishop
captures d6
rook captures d6
black to his horror find out that he is
about to lose the second pawn
so this is one of the wonderful trick
exist
if you open and continue with knight to
c6
okay let's continue with the main line
bishop to d7
and after this my recommendation is once
again you played this very tricky move
knight to e5
so white intention is very obvious he
wants to take on d7 and obtain the
bishop pair
and believe it or not black should allow
it by playing
knight to f6
but the obvious question come to your
mind that why black needs to do it
where he can chop up this bishop
straight away right
well yep he can accept one problem that
he has
straight away fallen into
white tricky platform
white has a fantastic move here
did you spot it
congratulation if you see the moon
queen 2f3
what a move
obviously white is attacking at multiple
location
including f7
[Music]
and black can't even play knight to f6
because of simple move
yup
queen captures b7
winning an important pawn
so that is right out of the equation
the only move exists here is
f6 defending on f7 and attacking the
knight
but i'm afraid
this doesn't solve black's problem
as after knight captures b5
white has multiple threads
number one
queen to h5 check and number two
queen captures d5
which unfortunately
black cannot defend both up there
black has tried two responses and let's
see each by turn
the first response
f captures e5
completely fails
due to the following tactic
queen captures d5
attacking two pawns so black response is
forced
he has to take on d5
but after our family fork on c7
not only white get his queen back
but the end result is
black has this horrible positional
weaknesses
double isolated e pawn
which can be a clear-cut target
in the upcoming end game
and as per the online database
white has almost
80 percent winning ratio from this
position
so this is the second trick exist
if your opponent capture on e5
one of the world's elite player shakir
mamijaro
has reached this position few times
and he preferred
knight to a6 instead of capturing on e5
which by force
leading to the exchange sack
after the following sequence
queen to h5 check
g6
knight captures g6
h captures g6
queen captures rook
and now although black is an exchange
down his idea is
he wants to activate the remaining piece
very quickly
with queen to d7
and get some sort of compensation as a
black
to be honest i don't believe it and just
one accurate move queen to h4
really dismiss this variation
well as per the engine the only good
move exists here is
queen captures b5
but after the following sequence
c4
so white is now getting his piece back
and after queen to c6 pontix and queen
takes
white can simply castle on the king side
and the net result is
white has catch up his peace development
and the same time he is an exchanger
i strongly recommend you to study
further some of the moves in detail
to use it in the tournament practice as
a complete surprise weapon
last but not least what happens if your
opponent allow you to capture this
bishop by playing
knight to f6
well then we are more than happy to take
it
but before we do it
first queen to f3 attacking on b7
making black queen to go on a passive
square
and after that
yup
knight captures d7
knight takes d7
and i recommend this simple plan with
bishop to e2 and queen to g3
where white obtained two bishop
and because black position remains
somewhat cramped
this position is always
slightly favoring the white camp
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile mini rapruta
against the nimsa with sicilian
remember at this point
when you opponent continue with bishop
to d7
play this tricky move knight to e5
and after bishop captures b5 and the
move queen to f3
i think no matter however black wriggles
if you play accurately from here onwards
white victory cannot be denied
thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care